hi my name is Mike and I'm an engineer
on the Android team I'm going to show
you how you can easily embed web content
into your application this includes HTML
CSS and JavaScript in addition to
displaying this content you can also
control it from your application this is
done with an embedded webview now the
Gmail application that's included with
Android actually uses an embedded
webview in order to display the contents
of the conversation we have all the HTML
fragments for each message in the
conversation stored in a database and
then we put to put those together and
display them in a web view but webview
actually looks like it's part of the
Gmail application because it is part of
the Gmail application for example if I
bring up the menu the menu contains all
the menu items you'd expect to see in
Gmail and not the kind of menu items
you'd expect to see in the browser
there's also two-way communication
between the content that's displayed in
the webview and the java application
that the Gmail application itself so for
example if I touch on the first item in
the list you can see that it expands and
the content for that comes from the
JavaScript that's running inside the
webview calling out into my Java code to
get the next fragment for HTML and
putting it back into the Dom you can
also have communication going the other
way
so if I star a message then my Java code
is going to push a change into the Dom
by executing some JavaScript and you can
see that here now if you want to use
these techniques yourself we have some
sample code available on the apps for
Android site that shows how to embed a
webview and how to have communication in
and out of that webview from your
activity using a webview is a really
good option if you already have a lot of
content and HTML and JavaScript and it
provides a really nice seamless
experience for the user